maybe fight you know maybe I can lower
my rent by saying the West Village is
gonna be a target well clearly clearly
New York is al Qaeda's number one target
in the world al Qaeda has an obsession
with New York it's had an obsession with
New York almost since its founding in
the 90s 93 ramzi yousef who trained in
our kind of training camp launched an
operation against the World Trade Center
he didn't manage to collapse the
building but people died in that attack
and al Qaeda of course on 911 tired of
New York again and Al Qaeda's leaders
have made no secret that they would like
to attack New York yet another time so
unfortunately New York also Washington
the key al-qaeda targets in the United
States other cities in the United States
might be targeted but but I think the
risk is much much lower honestly with
with other cities but just because of
the symbolic importance in New York and
Washington al Qaeda were planning a
second wave of operations after nine
eleven there was sudden targets also in
the West Coast LAX the airport in los
angeles was a target alone in two
thousand so there are other cities as
well which are on al-qaeda's wish list
if you like and I within New York
obviously the NYPD their concern is
clearly about some of the transport
infrastructure subway system commuter
trains anywhere in New York where crowds
gather New York is a media capital of
the world and definitely United States
and so any attack here really would get
incredible media coverage for al-qaeda
and bin Laden once said to mullah omar
the head of the taliban that the media
battle is ninety percent at the war I'd
be very surprised that there's not being
more
warded operations launched by al-qaeda
against New York and in recent times but
but that said you know that the US and
intelligence agency is the NYPD are
doing an amazing job right now billions
of dollars have been directed against
protecting the city it's very hard for
al-qaeda to infiltrate operatives here
they don't have any logistical setup
they don't have any real support base in
the New York area so it could be very
difficult for them to launch any sort of
attacks or acquired bomb-making
materials the plots we have seen here
and be more the lone wolf variety in
2004 there was a plot on Herald Square
subway system but it was a one guy
operating on his own he didn't have any
links to any of the al Qaeda leadership
at all and it was just a self-starting
type of attack plot which was thought
I'd and he's now serving as a
significant sentence so New York is the
you know there's a reason why a lot of
the money in the US counterterrorism has
been divert to New York and and and
there's very good reason for that and
that's the New York would be a very
symbolic target for al-qaeda